alzheimer in früher jugend und alzheimer
früh erkennt wie das in zukunft gelingen
könnte und wie die forscher darauf
gekommen sind jetzt in konstanten
wechsel schon in jungen jahren von
menschen von alzheimer betroffen sein
für sie ist es besonders dramatisch wenn
sie mitten im berufsleben stehen und
dement werden
und gerade bei ihnen denkt erst mal
niemand an demenz wenn wie vergesslich
werden und diese ausfälle immer weiter
zunehmen gerade für sie ist die
früherkennung wichtig und die könnte
bald besser werden forscher des columbia
university medical center
anhand eines laborexperimente eine neue
art der frühzeitigen alzheimer diagnose
entwickelt die menschen haben eine art
innere gps-system ein navi in unser
gehirn das und bei der orientierung im
raum hilft so können wir uns an wege die
wir bereits gegangen sind erinnern und
von einem ort zum anderen finden also
laufen wir nicht nur der nase nach
sonder tatsächlich zielstrebig auf ein
viel zu maßgeblich dafür verantwortlich
ist in unserem gehirn der hypo campus
und auch der entropie neue cortex bei
menschen die an alzheimer erkranken
funktionieren diese gehirnbereiche nicht
mehr einwandfrei die sogenannten tau
proteine fallen auseinander und können
so die reibungslose navigation nicht
mehr gewährt mit dato unbekannt war in
welchem bereich des gehirns größere
schäden aufgrund des protein verfalls
entstehen anhand von ihnen die jahre
gekommenen mäusen konnten die
wissenschaftler zeigen dass ein mit
kaputten tau-protein besetzter and
original apotex erheblich größeren
schaden anrichtet wie die forscher im
fachmagazin neuron berichten könne man
zudem schon äußerst früh die
auswirkungen eines befalls bemerken
zitat diese studie ist die erste die
einen solchen zusammenhang von alzheimer
und schäden an den grip feld belegt
diese erkenntnis könnte entscheidend
sein
um die entwicklung der frühen alzheimer
symptome zu verstehen darunter auch die
neigung sich zu verirren erklärt edvard
moser vom kavli institute
diese entdeckung wird die behandlung von
alzheimer maßgeblich verändern herren
darf vom columbia university medical
center zufolge könne man in zukunft
orientierungstest entwickeln die die
menschen im frühstadium erkennen die
früher man die krankheit diagnostizieren
kann desto eher könne man
therapeutischer geben und somit deren
wirkung erhöhen wenn man bedenkt dass
die immense bedeutung des hippocampus in
bezug auf den orientierungssinn jahr
2005 bestätigt werden konnte
bitter ein großer schritt in einer
relativ kurzen zeit für die
gehirnforschung was meint ihr wissen wir
von viel über unser nervensystem oder
bleiben noch viele wichtige fragen offen
und wenn ja welche
ich freue mich auf eure meinung und
natürlich auf einen daumen nach oben und
ein kostenloses abo dafür einfach hier
klicken und da gibt es noch ein weiteres
spannendes video und was bleibt mir noch
zu sagen genau bis dann bleibt